well catholic charities of southern
nevada one of the oldest service
organizations in the valley is bringing
back in-person volunteers as a
non-profit they need all the help they
can get they serve thousands of people
every day here in our valley in
different ways hector mejia is live near
owens and las vegas boulevard with the
details good morning hector catholic
charities does such great work what do
they need right now
yeah a very special mission hey there
sheri good morning they need volunteers
to help stock shelves help arrange
things make the
boxes with food and also just to serve
people and talk with people we actually
have a volunteer donna and her husband
chuck they've been volunteers for just
about five years tell us
how did you start and what kept bringing
you back good morning good morning
well my granddaughter needed to do some
volunteer work for schools so we came
here because they had a saturday
opportunity to volunteer
and we never left that was five years
ago and you're still here that's right
that's right
it's a great place to be
the staff here is wonderful
caring to all the clients and the
clients are wonderful too you know it's
great to be able to give back a little
bit and help people out how do you feel
when you're walking out so you're still
volunteering back again now that they
brought back the volunteer program but
when you walk out you know what are your
feelings
oh you feel really good you feel like
you've made a difference in the world
like
especially with everything that's been
going on recently
there's so much hardship that when you
come here you actually be able you can
feel like you've elevated someone and
you've made them feel better so that
makes you feel good so show us a little
bit of let's say your shift just started
what would you normally do as soon as
you walk in well basically we can do a
couple of things we can either fill
boxes
get those ready to give to the clients
my personal favorite is i like to
organize the shelves we'll bring out
a product and then we'll straighten
things out we'll stalk you know put this
this is me
donna and chuck so who is faster at uh
you know organizing the shelves or who
has the eye for it
she's just that that's the way she is
you can really like wait that needs to
be
over just one inch to the left yes i'm a
little funny that way but it looks
beautiful and when people come in here
to shop it makes it easy for them to
find things and it makes them
feel like this is a great place to be i
feel great i can get my goodies and go
home and feel like i've had a great day
awesome donna and chuck thank you very
much for your time and also for setting
your clock your alarm clock a little
earlier than usual this morning to join
us so we'll be posting all the details
on our website the food pantry is open
monday through friday and we'll be
posting the information in case you need
some assistance yourself or if you'd
like to volunteer we have the
information on your screen we have the
address phone number as well as the
website if you need to uh get more
resources for now we're going to have to
send it back to you guys reporting live
from catholic charities hector mejia
back to you guys all right hector thank
you very much they do such good work
over there